สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงอุ้ย
ทำไมมาเรียบร้อยจังเลยค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูเรียมวันนี้วัน
อะไรคะวันนี้วัน
อังคาร
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
11 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนตุลาคมค่ะปีพ.ศอะไร
คะพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะพ.ศ
2022 ค่ะตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะครูเรียมตอน
นี้ 15 น 11 นาทีค่ะอืม 15:00 นแล้วว้าว
ว้าวใช่ค่ะครูหญิงอืมอุ๊ยทำไมวันนี้ครู
เรียมดูเรียบร้อยจังเลยคะดูเรียบดูแบบพูด
ช้าๆแล้วก็ใช่ค่ะครูหญิงทำไมเรียบร้อย
เป็นเป็นนางเอกละครเหรอคะใช่ค่ะคิดว่าดู
ละครไทยเยอะมาก
ๆแล้วก็ดูแล้วก็อยากเป็นนางเอก
คิดว่าตัวเองเป็นนางเอกละครค่ะอืเพราะว่า
นางเอกละครไทยนะคะนางเอกละครไทยเนี่ย
เรียบร้อยพูดเพราะพูดช้าๆสวัสดีค่ะแล้วก็
ยิ้มยิ้มอย่างเดียวนะคะหรือไม่ถ้าไม่ยิ้ม
ก็ร้องไห้ร้อง
ไห้อ๋อแล้ว
ใช่มแล้วนางเอกเนี่ยงั้นนางเอกละครไทยก็
ต้องเป็นผู้หญิงเหรอคะใช่ค่ะนางเอกละคร
ไทยก็จะเป็นผู้หญิงอืสวยๆสวยมากๆสวยที่
สุดในเรื่องถ้ามีละครไทย 1 เรื่องนางเอก
ต้องสวยที่สุดมั้ยใช่อืเอ้าแล้วนางเอกมี
คู่มยคะมีคู่มนางเอกมีคู่ค่ะคู่กับพระ
เอกพระเอกก็ต้องเป็นผู้ชายหรอคะใช่ค่ะพระ
เอกเป็นผู้ชายอืหล่อหล่อมากๆออุ้ยก็นาง
เอกสวยพระเอกหล่อก็คู่
กันใช่ค่ะอืครุชอบดูละครไทยมั้ยเมื่อ
ก็เมื่อก่อน
ดูแต่ตอนนี้ที่บ้านไม่มีทีวี
อืตอนนี้ดูใน YouTube ก็ได้นะคะอโอเหรอคะ
แบบไม่ได้ดูละครไทยละครอะไรก็ไม่เคยดู
ละครไทยละคร
เกาหลีละครจีนละคร
ญี่ปุ่นฝรั่งอ่ะดูบ้างนิดหน่อยอืก็ไม่
ค่อยได้ดูละคร
ออแต่ว่าเมื่อก่อนใช่มั้ยเมื่อก่อนครู
หญิงดูละครไทยดูค่ะครูเรียมเมื่อก่อน
เนี่ยเวลานะเวลาประมาณ 20:30 นค่ะครู
เรียมใช่ๆเห็นคูเรียมก็
รู้
ประมาณ 20:00 นครึ่งอืมนะ 20:30 นเนี่ย
ละครไทยจะมาทีวีไทยใช่มั้ยคะทีวีไทยช่อง 3
แล้วก็ทีวีช่อง 7 ทีวีไทยจะมี 2 ช่องใช่
มั้ยช่อง 3 กับช่อง 7 ที่เวลา 20:30 น
เนี่ยเราเนี่ยจะรอรอดู
ละครว่าถ้าไม่มาดูไม่มี YouTube ให้ดู
แล้วอ่ะใช่อก็จะอ้อมไม่ได้ดู
อืพอพรุ่งนี้ไปโรงเรียนก็จะแบบเพื่อนๆ
เนี่ยคุยกันละครไทยเราก็จะแบบอืไม่ได้ดู
อ่ะนอนเงี้ยไม่ได้ไม่ได้ไม่ได้ไม่ได้
เมื่อก่อนครูหญิงดูละครไทยครูเรียมอ่ะคะ
ครูเรียมชอบดูละครไทยมั้ยคะ
เรียมชอบดูละครไทยเมื่อก่อนนะ
แต่ว่าตอนนี้ตอนนี้ก็ดูแต่แบบดู
แบบน้อยนอืถ้าเกิดเพื่อนมีเพื่อนบอกว่า
ละครไทยดีเรื่องนี้ดีเตมก็จะแบบอ๋อไปดูใน
YouTube นิดหน่อยอ่าใส่แบบอุ๊ยหรือว่า
เรียมละครไทยเรื่องนี้นะสนุกมากเวลาดูนะ
แบบวู้สนุกเงี้ยครูเรียมก็จะดูจ้ใช่ๆอ่า
แต่ไม่ไม่รอไม่รอหน้าทีวี 20:30 นแล้วก็
แบบรอดูละครไทยไม่มีแล้วเนาะไม่ค่ะไม่ครู
หญิงเรียมอยากคุยว่าในละครไทยเนี่ยจะมี
นางเอกอ่าใช่ผู้หญิง
สวยมีพระเอกผู้ชายหล่อหมดแล้วเหรอคะละคร
ไทยมีอีกค่ะ
เพถ้ามีแค่ 2 คนก็ไม่สนุกเนาะไม่สนุกอื
ละครที่แบบสนุกมากๆคนดูชอบดูมากๆต้องมี
นาง
ร้ายนางร้ายนี่เป็นผู้ชายหรือผู้หญิงคะ
นางร้ายเป็นผู้หญิงอืแล้วนางร้ายเนี่ย
เป็นคนดีมยนางเอกเนี่ยนางเอกที่ครูเรียน
บอกเนี่ยนะคะใจดีสวยเรียบร้อยแล้วนางร้าย
เนี่ยเหมือนนางเอกมั้ยนางร้ายเป็นคนไม่ดี
อืมนางร้ายเนี่ยนางเอกเนี่ยยิ้มมากๆแล้ว
ก็ร้อง
ไห้แล้วก็ยิ้มแล้วก็ร้องไห้แล้วนางร้าย
ล่ะคะนางร้ายเป็นยังไงอ่ะเวลาถ้านักเรียน
ดูละครไทยอ่ะนักเรียนจะรู้มยคนนี้นางร้าย
นางร้ายก็จะกรีด
อนักเรียนไม่ได้ยินนะคะครูเรียมตัดเสียง
ให้ใช่มั้ยใช่มันจะรีดังกว่านี้อีกมันแบบ
ใช่นางร้ายใช่ค่ะแล้วก็ไม่ยินะคะนักเรียน
ค่ะตอนนี้เป็นนางเอกอะไรค่ะครูหญิงเป็น
นางร้ายให้ก็ได้ค่ะค่ะครู
เรี่มสุดยอดค่ะครูหญิงเป็นนางร้ายนะคะครู
หญิงไม่ดีนางร้ายใช่นางร้ายเนี่ยตาจะ
แบบจิกตาใช่มั้ยตามากูหญิงไม่เข้าใจใช่
ครูเรียมเนี่ยเป็นนางร้ายดีตรงไหนรู้มั้ย
คะครูเรียมเนี่ยตาโตมันจะดูน่ากลัวไงใช่
มั้ยนางร้ายแหละคูหญิงตาเล็กๆอ่ะ
ใช่มั้เจ็บมยคะแล้วก็อีกอย่างนึงอีกอย่าง
นึงนะคะที่ครูหญิงรู้สึกว่านางร้ายของ
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยไม่ใช่แค่กรีดอย่างเดียวนะ
ถ้าเมื่อก่อนนะเมื่อก่อนตอนครูหญิงเด็กๆ
เนี่ยนางร้ายเนี่ยกรี๊ดใช่มยแล้วก็ตาก็จะ
แบบตลอดเวลาแล้วก็ต้องทาลิปสติกสีแดงอ๋อ
ลิปสติกทาแบบเนี้ยเหรอ
ลิปสติกสีแดงเลยค่ะครูเรียมใช่
ค่ะเห็นมยเออครูเรียมได้นะถึงมว่าเสียง
ครูเรียมเนี่ยเวลาพูดเสียงเนี่ยนางเอก
สวัสดีค่ะแต่ว่าลิปสติกสีแดงแล้วก็ตา
เนี่ยสวัสถ้าถ้าถ้าครูเรียมอ่ะถ้านางเอก
นางเอกเนี่ยนางเอกสวัสดีนักเรียนทำยังไง
คะสวัสดีค่ะแล้วถ้านางรา
สวัสดีนัก
เรียนสวัสดีค่ะเออนี่เห็นมยไม่เหมือนกัน
นะคะดูตาสิ
ค่ะ
เอ้าครูหญิงมีนางร้ายแล้วถ้าเกิดผู้ชาย
ล่ะถ้าเกิดเป็นผู้ชายที่ไม่ดีล่ะระร้ายมย
คะไม่ใช่เอ้าก็มีนางเอกเป็นผู้หญิงที่ดี
มีนางร้ายเป็นผู้หญิงไม่ดีมีพระเอกเป็น
ผู้ชายที่ดีผู้ชายไม่ดีไม่พูดพระร้ายเหรอ
คะไม่ค่ะจะพูดว่าตัวร้าย
อ๋อแล้วตัวร้ายที่เป็นผู้ชายเนี่ยตัวร้าย
ที่เป็นผู้หญิงใช่ไหมมนางร้ายเนี่ยทาปาก
สีแดงแล้วก็กรี๊ดกรี๊ดกี๊ดกรีดแล้วตัว
ร้ายที่เป็นผู้ชายอ่ะเป็นยังไงอ่ะไม่กรีด
นะไม่
กรีดตัวร้ายผู้ชายก็จะคิดว่ามีหนวดนะเหรอ
ใชนักเรียนตัวร้ายผู้ชายอ่ะผิวดำส่วนใหญ่
นะจะผิวดำใช่มยแล้วก็มีหนวดมีหนวดแล้วก็
มีปืนอใช่ค่ะหรือถ้าแบบเป็นตัวร้ายผู้ชาย
ที่หล่อหน่อยเขาก็จะมีตาที่
แบบเป็นคนไม่ดีอ่ะค่ะคิดไม่ดีบ่อยๆตลอด
เวลาอืมใช่ตัวร้ายหรือว่าตัวโกงใช่มยใช่
ค่ะอืเวลาครูเรียมดูละครไทยหมดหรือยังคะ
มีพระเอกใช่มั้ยมีพระเอกคนนี้เนาะเป็นพระ
เอกคนที่ 1 เนี่ยนะคะใช่คนมีพระเอกพระเอก
เอ้าพระเอกมีนางเอกนางเอกแล้วก็มีนางร้าย
นางร้ายเดี๋ยวทาปากให้นางร้ายก่อนนิดนึง
ใช่ๆครูเรียทาปากสีแดงหน่อยค่ะ
เออนางร้ายเนี่ยอ่ะแล้วก็มีตัวโกงหรือว่า
ตัวร้ายใช่มยตัวโกงใช่แล้วก็มีตัวโกงตัว
ร้ายมีหนวดอืออืแล้วละครไทยเนี่ยเวลาที่
เราดูใช่มยดูตอนที่ 1 ตอนที่ 2 ตอนที่ 3
ดูจนจบตอนสุดท้ายเนี่ยพระเอกกับนางเอกได้
คู่กันใช่มั้ยคะใช่ค่ะตอนสุดท้ายพระเอก
กับนางเอกก็จะรักกันอืม
แล้วนางร้ายกับตัวโกงได้คู่กัน
มยบางเรื่องก็คู่กันอืแต่ว่าหลายๆเรื่อง
ก็โดนตำรวจตำรวจจับใช่มเพราะว่าเป็นคนไม่
ดี
ไงใช่ๆ
เออเนาะอันนี้ก็เป็นละครไทยแล้วมีอะไรอีก
คะครูเรียนละไทแล้วในลละครก็จะเล่า
ว่าเป็นคนรวยหรือว่าเป็นคนจนอืแล้วละคร
ไทยมากๆเนี่ยพระเอกผู้ชายหล่อเนี่ยนะพระ
เอกเนี่ยเป็นคนรวยมยคะพระเอกจะหล่อแล้วก็
รวยโอแล้วนางเอกล่ะนางเอกเนี่ยสวยรวยมย
นางเอกก็สวยแต่แบบจนมากอจนแต่มีกระเป๋า
หลุยวิกตองนะคะนางเอกอ่ะไม่รู้นะคะแต่แบบ
บางเรื่องนางเอกนางเอกที่เป็นผู้หญิงก็
รวยมาก
อือืแต่ว่าพระเอกกับนางเอกจะเป็นคนดีนาง
ร้ายล่ะคะนางร้ายเนี่ยปากสีแดงเนี่ยรวย
มยนางร้ายที่รวยๆก็มีนางร้ายที่จนแบบไม่
มีเงินก็มีอืแล้วตัวโกงอ่ะผู้ชายไม่ดีรวย
มยส่วนใหญ่ละครไทยรวยเนาะรวยมีทั้งรวย
แล้วก็ไม่รวยแต่ในตอนจบนะมันจะมีตอน 1  2
3  4  5 ใช่มยในตอนที่ในตอนจบเนี่ยก็จะ
โดนตำรวจจับแล้วก็จนอืใช่เพราะว่าจะเป็น
คนไม่ดีคิดไม่ดีนะใช่แล้วถ้าครูหญิงดูรูป
นี้อืครูเรียมมีรูปละครไทยให้ดูเหรอคะใช่
ๆใช่ให้ครูหญิงดูดูว่าใครคือนาง
เอกนางเอกต้องเป็นผู้หญิงที่ใส่เสื้อสี
ฟ้ากำลังจับผมคนนี้ใช่มั้ยคะใช่ค่ะกำลัง
จับผมอุ๊ยครูหญิงตอบถูกครูเรียนรู้มยทำไม
ครูหญิง
รู้ทำยังไงคะรู้ได้ยังไงก็ครูเรียมบอกว่า
นางเอกเนี่ยต้องเรียบร้อยแล้วก็ชอบร้อง
ไห้ก็ดูหน้าของผู้หญิงที่ใส่เสื้อสีฟ้า
เค้าทำหน้า
แบบเหมือนจะร้อง
[เพลง]
ไห้ครูเลียมทำหน้าเหมือนเค้าหน่อยสิ
คะนักเรียนคิดว่า
เหมือนเหมือนเหมือนักเรียนเหมนเรนักเรียน
คิดว่านักเรียนคิดว่าเหมือนพิมพ์ 1 นะคะ
ถ้านักเรียนคิดว่าไม่เหมือนก็พิมพ์ 1 นัก
เรียนจะได้พิมพ์ 1 เท่านั้นโอเคแล้วใคร
เป็นพระเอกเป็นพระเอกเดี๋ยวครูเรียมผู้
ชายที่ใส่หมวกเนี่ยต้องเป็นไม่ใช่พระเอก
เพราะว่าครูเรียมบอกว่าพระเอกเป็นคนดี
หล่อผูเรียนบอกว่าตัวโกงมีหนวดแล้วก็มี
ปืน
คูเรียมผู้ชายที่ใส่หมวกใส่เสื้อเชิตสี
ขาวเนี่ยเเป็นเเป็นตัวโกงเหรอคะ
อ๋อคนนี้เป็นพระเอกอ้าทำไมพระเอกมีหนวด
เราก็มีปืนด้วยพระเอกในเรื่องนี้เป็นแบบ
เหมือนเค้าเรียกว่าหนักนอำเภออ้าปลัดเป็น
ปลัดที่แบบคล้ายๆกับตำรวจออ๋อแต่ดูหน้า
ได้นะเห็นมั้ยดูหน้าของพระเอกดูตาของเค้า
เนี่ยเป็นคนดีเห็นมยเคมีปืนก็จริงนะคะแต่
ตาเ้าเป็นคนดีไงใช่มั้ยดูตาดูตาเป็นคดีดี
ใช่ๆเ้าก็ดูเหมือนดูนางเอกไงนางเอกดูตาแ
อัน
นี้คนดีๆเขจะตงตอย่างงี้ไงเออแล้วใครเป็น
นางร้ายเป็นนางร้ายรู้เลยค่ะผู้หญิงที่มี
ใส่ถุงมือสี
ขาวถูสีแดงเห็นมยหูยครูหญิงตอบถูกอืครู
หญิงก็เป็นคนไทยนะคะดูละครไทยเดี๋ยวครู
เรียมเป็นนางเอกูหญิงเป็นนางร้ายแต่เรียม
ปากแดงนะคะ
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะครูหญิงปาก
ชมพูนเรียนบอกทำอะไรเ้าแล้วแต่ครูหญิงครู
หญิงไม่รู้ว่าคคนคนนะคะคนไหนเป็นตัวโกงคะ
ครูเรียมอ่ะครูหญิงลองหาซิคนไหนคือตัวโก
ตัวโกตัวโกต่อกันนะคะเพราะว่ายังมีผู้ชาย
ใส่เสื้อลายสกอตแล้วก็มีผู้ชายที่ใส่
เสื้อสีดำอีก 2 คนอือ่ะเรียมขยายให้ดูได้
ค่ะใหญ่ๆได้มย
คะครูหญิงคิดว่าต้องเป็นผู้ชายที่ใส่
เสื้อลายสกอตค่ะครูเหี่ยมคนนี้เป็นอะไรคะ
เป็นตัวโกงครูหญิงเห็นหน้าเหรอคะดูหน้าเิ
เห็นปากเค้าค่ะปากเึเหมือนเค้าใช่มยเป็น
คนไม่ดีแล้วก็เขาก็ไม่มีคู่เพราะว่าผู้
ชายคนนี้คู่กับผู้หญิงคนนี้ผู้ชายข้าง
ล่างอีก 1 คนที่หันหน้าตรงก็คู่กับผู้
หญิงไงเพราะว่าคนไม่ดีไม่มีผู้หญิงชอบออ
อุ๊ยครูหญิงใช่มคะครูหญิงตอบถูก
อคนไทยดูละครไทยตั้งแต่เด็กตอนนี้ไม่ดู
แต่ว่าเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยดูทุกวันทุกวันทุก
วันออเข้าใจอืแล้วนักเรียนล่ะนักเรียนดู
ดูรูปนี้แล้วรู้
มยดูรูปนี้แล้วรู้มว่าคนไหนเป็นพระเอกนาง
เอกนางร้ายตัวโกงตัวร้ายอืมรู้รู้มั้ยใช่
เวลาที่คนไทยเนี่ยดูดูละครไทยนะคะผู้หญิง
คนที่เป็นนางร้ายทาปากสีแดงเนี่ยคนไทยที่
ดูละครเนี่ยก็จะแบบไม่ชอบไม่ชอบผู้หญิงคน
นี้เลยเวลาดูก็คิดหืหือตดูอยจะตกผู้หญิง
คนนี้ใช่แต่พอนางเอกใช่มั้ยนางเอกเนี่ย
เป็นผู้หญิงเรียบร้อยแล้วก็ร้องไห้คนไทย
ดูอื
ไม่เป็นไรนะไม่เป็นไรนะเดี๋ยวไปนางร้าย
ให้อันนี้เวลาคนไทยดูละครนะคะแล้วครูหญิง
ครูหญิงเคยดูดูละครแล้วร้องไห้
มั้ย
ไม่อเหรครูเรียมเวลาครูเรียมดูละครไทยครู
เรียมร้องไห้หรอร้องไห้เ้าร้องไห้ตอนไหน
ร้องไห้ตอนนางเอกร้องไห้อ๋อเพราะว่าตัว
ร้ายใช่มตัวร้ายเนี่ยก็จะมาตบนางเอกเคิด
กำลังคิดดูแล้วก็คิดคิดว่าตัวเองเป็นนาง
เอกออก็เลยแบบเออร้องทำไมไม่ต้องร้องเลย
นะร้องไปน่ะเขาก็ไม่รักแกหรอกเขารักฉัน
อันนี้นางร้ายนะคะนักเรียนอันนี้แอคชั่น
นะคะอันนี้ไม่ใช่ชีวิตจริงนะคะอันนี้ครู
หญิงแอคชั่นเฉยๆดูเหมือนมากมานักเรียนบอก
นั้นบอกไม่ต้องดูละครไทยแล้วดูครูเรียม
เป็นนางเอกนะคะครูหญิงเป็นนางร้ายนางร้าย
มันสนุกนะคะนักเรียนเวลาเราเล่นมันรู้สึก
แบบแต่ว่าเวลาดูแล้วจะรู้สึกแบบหือยากจะ
ตกนะคะครูหญิงอยากจะมีทุเรียนนะคะทุเรียน
เหม็นๆนะคะนักเรียนทุเรียนกำลังจะพ
พูดนี่ป่ะอันนี้ทุเรียนมั้ยคะคุเรียนนี่
เนาะทุเรียนนะคะนักเรียนเอทุเรียนไปตบใช่
มั้ยใช่ค่ะเวลานางร้ายคนที่เล่นเป็นนาง
ร้ายมาเดินที่ตลาดแล้วคนไทยเนี่ยขาย
ทุเรียนมาแล้วใช่มั้ยไม่ซื้อเอาไปเลยนะ
เอาไปเลยนะคนไทยมีทุเรียนน่าสพี่คะพี่คะ
ละครค่ะไปเลยค่ะไม่จริงหรอกแกชอบปุบนาง
เอกของฉันละครนางเอกฉันเนี่ยร้องไห้ฉันน
สงสารนางเอกจริงๆไปเลยนะทุเรียนกว้างนะี่
ค่ะหนูหนูเล่นละครค่ะพี่หนูเล่นละครตัว
จริงหนูเป็นคนดีมากโอเคแต่ไม่ขายให้
ไปอันนี้คนไทยเมื่อก่อนแมาใช่เออโอแต่ตอน
นี้โอเคแล้วตอนนี้เข้าใจแล้วใช่มยตอนนี้
เข้าใจแล้วค่ะอืเนาะก็นี่ก็เป็นละครไทย
เนาะไม่รู้ว่าละครของประเทศนักเรียน
เหมือนละครไทยมามมีพระเอกใช่มั้ยผู้ชาย
หล่อคนดีมีนางเอกผู้หญิงสวยมีนางร้ายผู้
หญิงปากสีแดงแล้วก็มีตัวโกงผู้ชายที่มี
หนวดประเทศนักเรียนมีมั้ยละครไทยต้องมี
ทุกเรื่องนะคะใช่ 4 คาแรคเตอร์นี้สนุกไม่
สนุกค่ะไม่สนุกเพราะว่าคนไทยก็จะแบบใหย่
นางร้ายมันเลยลูกตบมันเลยเี้ยอันนี้คนไทย
ดูละครพอแล้วค่ะครูหญิงไม่ต้องตบใครแล้ว
ค่ะเวลาเวลาหมดแล้วอืเวลาหมดแล้วเลยนะคะ
ไม่เป็นไรนะคะนักเรียนก็ลองไปหาดูเนาะ
ละครไทยไม่รู้จะได้ภาษาไทยหรือเปล่าเแต่
กรีดกีดอกรีทนะคะก็งั้นครูหญิงกับครู
เรียมก็หมดเวลาไปแล้วเราไปดูละครไทยกันดี
กว่านะคะครูเรียมใช่ค่ะนักเรียนชอบคลิป
นี้ก็กดไลค์กดแชร์กด Subscribe ด้วยนะคะ
ใช่แล้วค่ะเดี๋ยวเรา 2 คนไปกก่อนนะคะบ๊าย
บายสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะไปได้แล้ว
ค่ะ